hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to part two of Steve office
getting out of there getting out of
there moving on I took a breather from
the first part just cuz it was like holy
back off a second there but you know
what I haven't I haven't actually
enjoyed the last book just because it
was like a first day who's a non-stop
onslaught of like really cheap jump
scares but some good ones
Lix did it was like they wouldn't stop I
actually enjoyed it quite a bit
after I backed up and took a breather
god damn it didn't let me get my breath
much against is a good quality of a game
okay so this is part two we leave off
part one it oh good
trails of blood lots of doors Oh No
are you real are you real or are you
just sounded noises are you just noise
and things
this one's flickering ah that's a real
thing closing that excuse me you go eff
off and die please thank you what what I
didn't mean to open that one there's
miss I already forgot what a lovely
painting ah
regards ah oh god damn it
Oakley cool is it huh
okay blood goes here was the follow the
blood thingy get out of the way I'm
falling the blood where's the blood
going no now there's wait
oh crap let's give me need to go just
leads back to the beginning oh hey look
at that I got a key okay I did it done
did it yeah
ah where was the thing it was an actual
there was uh Wow
where's the thingy where is the thing ah
where is it was he all there no that's
not it was like it was past it I know I
did he oh that's right it was over on
this wall okay the first part oh what a
lovely plant that's clipping through the
ceiling I could see that the budget was
just after a novel in this game - where
are you you same bastards get to fall
into it oh good there's the light switch
over there
really
Oh God
Joe not really
Kyle ugh leave me okay
I remember it was kinda left and towards
the middle area I just got a BAM baby oh
yeah you like me now get outta my way
cooing Gary you ain't even kind of scary
haha okay now if I could just avoid
breaking the game I'll be just fine but
this is markiplier we're talking about
here game breaker extraordinary feat now
shut up ah you again
hey making me sick oh look at you hey
where am I supposed Stan where am I
supposed to use this thing here I got a
key
there's no other place to go I got it he
this is where I broke the game I don't
him do it again maybe maybe I got to go
in here turn off the lights which lady
and you don't dick with me
oh no nope time's up a jillion dopes to
infinity to infinity and beyond got the
key didn't I oh oh oh I turned off the
light in here too
oh hey there you are why don't you got
magical powers I'm kind of stuck I got a
key but I can't open it
I came over but can't I open it you
should be able to right
Oh what do they do wrong what did I do
wrong and the toy oh that was grody I'm
gonna get I'm gonna flip through the
game again ah lady are you oh hi aisle 8
Oh
what is wrong with you you're swaying
your hips way too much oh I don't know I
don't know it's not it don't work it
don't flip-flop and war don't work the
keys there another key or something is I
supposed to unlock something I supposed
to do Oh God oh oh oh
dammit don't do that
oh god is there something is there some
reason there suck my god okay let's try
this again I think I need I think what
needs to happen is I need to trigger the
lady before I the key will be usable or
something
that's my only guest sometimes these
things need to go in a specific sequence
or else they won't work back in the
bottle boom baby
I can't Joe though I do die I can't I
literally can't seem to progress in the
game
cuz I don't know if something is bugged
or if I'm missing something but Wow
now I got a key ah there we go
oh oh I got it oh okay I get it
finally there was a key like hidden
somewhere okay okay we're back
son of a [ __ ] dog ain't gonna get me
this time dick suck on those biscuits oh
hi I'm coming to get me well I mean
that's coming to get me but I mean dog
oh please tell me I'm not bone
can I say Dave save in the slot see
that's good right that's good good job
me
I still hear the doze where am I going
what am i doing Oh No
what am i doing with my life I asked up
that myself I asked myself shut up okay
no one cares about your problems
shut up I see the exit you can't stop me
oh good good just what I want it more
dead good alright then the second one no
one took longer mostly cuz I had to go
back over and over again still not bad I
wanna see how this damn stuff go
thank you all so much for watching click
annotations for bars and plan
so arbitrary and you mother I would
never
[Music]
the seller seller
so scared at meeting guru